[Música]
votar é competições de robôs mas é um
professor universitário um livro que
fala coisas assim o caso mais feliz bom
isto começou tudo com um desafio e um
desafio ao qual na altura também foi
chamado é que em 1994 uma competição de
roubos em frança
o jornalista português do expresso rui
carvalho de seu novo sistema seja feita
que sempre andou muitas destas coisas já
não está no arquivo desafiou que uma
equipa portuguesa de participação em uma
competição de robôs uno ano sinto que eu
gostaria mesmo é que o pne e é o que
aconteceu foi que é nós na altura eu
tinha acabado de chegar do outro tinha
feito nos estados unidos e é quem assim
do céu aos trambolhões volta o técnico e
uma colega minha tinha um grupo de
alunos que aceitar o desafio e virou pra
mim e meu pai já tem muitas coisas no
banho tempo para mais nada porque não
pega e licita vamos lá ver o que
acontece
e foi assim com suas vidas mas ficava
mal sabia que ela estava fazendo por
causa daquela brincadeira e fomos então
o festival internacional de ciência e
tecnologia assim que se chamava e
parceiros com o hubble que era isso que
estava o nosso primeiro ou em um dos
primeiros que fizeram o técnico mesmo sr
eletrotécnica que era pra ela foi
construída a partir de um carro até lá
quem manda lá e tinha uma confusão no
risco de controlar os nossos colegas que
estavam presentes você chama conversamos
christina é olhando peixes nem país
parece bem no time é igual ao gol passou
a chamar-se minutos
nós somos portugueses e portanto quem
quiser brincar com uma coisa que
aconteceu foi que desafiará
interessantes já na altura se falava
muito nos veículos que seguiam uma pista
desenhada no chão era uma espécie de
veículo automotor ia usar divisas
automática de veículos nas fábricas
também seria fazer coisas neste ano
só que além disso a pista tinha essa
característica do fundo ser e xadrez com
a vida mais difícil ou com visão ao
início de uma nova sobre as palhadas eu
tinha que ser capaz de agarrar os
disparos havia interrupções foi um
desafio
depois deste desafio que aconteceu foi
que nós começamos a fazer os gols e aí
todos os anos venho e os novos também
era sempre o mesmo
criativos é uma bonita porque eu queria
ter um design ambiental relembrou por um
boom tubarão em cima me perguntem por
que o senhor acha que o caso não vai
botar não sei porque complementa depois
disso apareceu o centauro central não
tinha é exigência de um homem a força
nunca houve tantas que era exatamente o
que é uma força que eu tinha juntou se
ao facto do central já foi o google
instant
eu quero é capaz por exemplo de explorar
em retas trabalho em curvas um
desenvolvimento é bastante está a seguir
a este foi um outro que se chamava e que
99 nos vemos muito potencial estávamos
que já tínhamos atingido seu nível de
qualidade e é provável que quem ganhou
mesmo foi uma vitória que nós tivemos
foi o conjunto da luz a 10 12 15 no
formato em que eu acho que a questão do
ano deu é que desenhar um robô que as
ruas já que se consumido antes as contas
continuaram não peço desculpa que não é
a maior das convidadas do vídeo porque
já é um cliente que estava filmando a
distância ea que o câmera - estava um
bocado nervoso mas não vou seguir a
pista
chegava uma zona onde não tinha que ser
capaz de encontrar algo que estava lá
fora dirigia sair a salvo e depois
trazia também uma coisa que meu nome era
relativamente simples investigar o hamas
quer aos 44
nessa altura nós não tínhamos completa
confiança ainda do nosso comuns em 2005
lula foi o princípio nós começamos a
perceber que essas coisas não eram faças
isso que já não era uma brincadeira um
kevin mais do que isso porque apesar de
estarmos habituados a universidade é
aquela coisa nos testes dos antigos das
conferências uma coisa sem levar nada
havia uma outra maneira já queria
problemas toda a gente pôde abusar com
aspectos práticos e aspectos teóricos
que eram importantes e com base nisso de
fato desenvolver as ideias e havia
marcado ainda por trás do pará na
hungria como se tivéssemos acaba de
ganhar o campeonato europeu de futsal é
tal forma que ele havia portugueses na
bancada estão os alunos foi o parceiro
ivan cavaleiro português que está rosto
lá como se tivéssemos feito foi na nossa
vida
em francês também acho mesmo que ela vai
cair não estavam contentes porque achava
que a gente ia gostar é bom lembrar nada
isto foi o primeiro passo
o passado é aí os dois anos nós queremos
começar um projeto os curativos no
técnico ms eo mel ea parceiros e muito
eu vou falar nela muito vocês amigos e
outra moça não sou mais mulher tem que
ter a opção de manuel barroso que levava
alguma forma parte do grupo inicial
fundou esse é que acaba em 97 estar numa
um novo evento que é um evento tenha
surgido a seguir o grande desafio de
acabar de ser vice de um computador
derrotar o campeão mundial de xadrez
garry kasparov
então eu tenho um estado com uma coisa
muito estranha que os vôos que chegavam
a volta porque era muito mais complicado
mais dinâmico no xadrez chamava sua boca
e ela parece ver nos outros e vamos
comprar ativos de vida por nós quem
conhece que já viu representações
públicas
sabe como é né uma vida para nós e com
essa lei é pra vocês só podem tem que
vir aqui gente foi quando o então menino
pyotr o mec
então fomos fomos fizemos o gol é a
primeira vez que o ovo se você não
imagina eu fui magrinha igual àquela que
o olho como bola e conseguiu andar atrás
dela
foi como se nós tivéssemos um momento
suas curvas no mundo certa forma alguns
problemas estavam recebendo 20 que é
importante uma mudança na percepção
conjunto bom foi tal maneira isto é
outro atrativo é o robocup federation
organiza juntamente com um conjunto
português o homem que transformou sua
imagem estão aqui no fio e um robô que
tem um desafio muito engraçado que
conquistam os meus colegas pesquisas
como em 2050 não faz norte a não ficar
muito nós entretanto se não acontecer o
oxigênio que em 2050 ter um equipe de
robótica para derrotar a equipa campeã
do mundo
o princípio era dotar o brasil não
acreditam eles não gostaram então
ficamos assim mas mais nele
bom isto foi o começo do futebol
robótico para nós e em 1998 a segunda
edição do robô quer participamos
a aes é o nosso bolso eram feitos
medalhas 1100 ac é o alto custo
este foi o primeiro gol que a gente
marcou o seu e na capital federal em um
som e de certa forma tira parte do
entusiasmo também não é bom ouvir o que
estava a dizer e gritávamos chamávamos
pelo menos marcar um gol e marcar um gol
para que tudo aquilo que está envolvido
já agora se não querem mais série é
muito importante porque apesar de ser um
simples jogo da bola em cima do animal é
os robôs tinham que saber onde estava o
tinha que saber onde estava nos estágios
podem evitar que o senhor avalia essa
altura tinha coisa agora já não tem
tenho que saber muito mais coisas bom e
agora vamos mostrar uma final 2 e 3 anos
entre duas equipas uma equipa holandesa
uma equipa chinesa é e vão ver o
contraste o 1° bom precisar o grau do
iatismo que é uma coisa que nós próprios
nos provam a equipe vai provar que era
da casa mas havia certeza muito mais
pessoas cristian e agora para que os
gols que passados todos estes anos são
capazes de localizar no campo sabe onde
é que estão todos conectados adversários
sabem o néctar bola também fazê-lo
informações play atrás da bola e tentava
roubar o no estádio bom e sabe marcar
gols no começo ela que está isto tudo
que está envolvido é capaz de nos dizer
várias coisas problemas no dia a dia que
podem ser resolvidos com técnicas foram
desenvolvidas aqui há um deus na forma
de uma companhia muito conhecida que foi
vendida à amazônia e que faz todo o
sistema da mensagem mas não foi
consumida por um colega que trabalhou no
local durante muitos anos e que fala
sempre foi por causa disso que construiu
aquela companhia de sucesso
isto foi o futebol mas o homem já não é
só algum tempo ficou lembrado tem
desafios por exemplo rosso de busca e
salvamento é em nós participamos novos
deus também há uma réstia de londrina
que é construída pelos colegas
americanos onde treinam
as equipas de busca e salvamento humanos
cães e também em tecnologia e que usava
no robocup precisamente para os robôs
vários países com queremos sempre
tentarem conseguir o melhor escola
naquela no desempenho naquela arena por
exemplo conseguiu encontrar o maior
número de vítimas que são bonecos com a
presença de pessoas e conferir nem
sempre fico logo começa a conquistar
este como o que está foi mais um dos
parceiros uma escala de faro como está
não fica complicada fora do vulgar mas
foi mais uma das categorias que a gente
tem que sumir foi o robô não tinha nada
a ver com as condições não tinha nada a
ver com futebol
a raposa foi mundial e também a certa
altura quando fizemos a primeira versão
esta é a segunda em conjunto como esta
só foi feita mesmo com a companhia
portuguesa conosco em nossa inclusão e
convém não consegue fazer aquelas coisas
todas
e temos aqui eu fui pra fazer um
controle remoto do ovo é sem estar a ver
o que está acontecendo assim eu tenho
que conseguir olhando em seus olhos do
google fazer um erro
nós agora estamos muito mais seus robôs
autônomos como aqueles que jogam à bola
quer dizer que as outras equipas de
busca e salvamento querem preferem que
uma esteja sempre no hu e assim nós
conseguimos viajar na altura começamos a
usar também é é quatro copas juntamente
vamos ver como nós temos mas temos mais
ou menos sofisticados das câmeras nos
apanhou conseguir saber onde estava o
noliko tudo isto foi pra nós
depois gostou mais um passo mais um
degrau na escada é e estamos assumiu
sempre que fazemos custam r4 concluiu o
bom nem sempre é verdade que nem sempre
as condições têm o melhor nos caráter
científico porque há coisas que
acontecem mas eu também encaro como um
desafio positivo para este jogo faz tudo
direitinho vai all-in tenta marcar ou
não entra na área porque o imitou regras
o guarda redes vai conseguir tirar de
boa a certa altura eu tentar matar não
consegue a bola foz vai ficar ou evita o
adversário dá uma voltinha tudo feito
uma volta volta outra vez com a bola
para a baliza tenta marcar gol no
concelho
é uma situação chata é é agora vai
é o que acontece é que de fato as
construções com muito simples e que não
tem nada sofisticado diz que nem sabem
muito mais para ganhar o jogo
walking pessoas conseguem ganhar é
provável que há muita crítica dentro da
unidade cirúrgica por causa disso mas eu
encaro isso como um desafio se nós não
conseguimos com a nossa consciência e
também resolver problemas destes
voluntários adversários então se calhar
não walter bom o desafio continuou e
continuou e vai pro portugal e vai pra
europa e em geral desde 2006 fazendo
isso e agora os convívios aqui há 12
meses em torres vedras 18ª edição do
festival nacional de robótica 18 edições
eu acho que nessa tal escala e por isso
trouxe o tema hoje pra mim
mais até do que sempre universitário
todos os outros que eu tenha feito mal o
que vou lembrar sempre é do que nós
fizemos nestas coisas quem praticou ato
em portugal
hoje em dia a cruz robótica por tudo
quanto é sítio é e tudo começou um carro
o precisamente com o festival nacional
de robótica em 2001 é estão imagens no
festival no técnico em 2011 já fizemos
duas divisões em lisboa com competições
fora portas um veículo autónomo square
em nova york o morro alto no salão nobre
do técnico conseguimos um feito vez
juniors que normalmente são pai 400 em
um total de 1 600 participantes que o
impedimento das escolas secundárias e
pista de condução autônoma assim porque
nós já falávamos condução autônoma em
2001 fizemos uma pista que é esta que
está em uma forma jamais envolvida que
agora evoluiu ainda mais têm sinais
trânsito têm zonas de obras têm as
linhas que gostaria de seguir em um
túnel onde tem que mudar a iluminação
tem que estacionar não se inclui ou não
sabem qual é o garoto estado que está
vago tem que evitar obstáculos que
aparecem de repente na pista e alguns
fazem isso em alguns desenvolvido por
portugueses já há muitos anos
bom no meio de tudo isto
nós neste momento o esquivo digital e
com isso nós neste momento estamos em
outra competição ea competição vai de
coisas também é uma das mais sérias
não estamos a desenvolver robôs como
estava fora o ex padrinho para um
hospital
o ipê o esgoto juntamente com mais com
eles do técnico pega meu corpo num
projecto europeu nesta área
depois se alargarmos para outros
projetos e investimentos e trabalhar com
crianças autistas mas mantemos o roubo
uma competição de robôs ramos doméstico
regional àquela senhora porque ela é uma
rapariga mas com o cabelo grisalho que é
está em casa quero manter uma grande
qualidade de vida e gosta de dizer em
quanto não pode estar acamada rumo onde
vai buscar um objeto não sei quando
olhas em duas mãos da sala que eu não
consigo
olha só ganhar a porta vai ver uma
pessoa possa se eu faço está super
ataque produzisse metal e um gasto
mínimo do arroz
alguns anos depois vamos ver é e agora
foi mais um grau continua a ser um
grande entusiasmo e eu acho que passando
uma mensagem similar está convivendo há
pouco é se alguma vez me disserem que
aqui ou aquelas causas que vocês não
acredito isso não interessa para nada
mas se manterá dentro dos padrões
normais
desconfiem porque às vezes um pouco as
causas que estão com os bolsos do nosso
eu acho que não vai acontecer mais
alunos que embora não sabe muito bem
quais são
[Música]